avec nous pour ce club de territoires
clairs Planchard bonjour Claire merci
d'être avec nous avec tristes en chef
pour les journaux du groupe Ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'Est de la France
Erwan l'ESTRO est avec nous bonjour
Erwan merci beaucoup d'être la directeur
conseil à l'institut de sondage au doxa
et comme tous les mois justement on va
regarder votre baromètre au doxa pour
Public Sénat et la presse régionale la
démission du maire de Saint-Brévin remis
en lumière la question des violences
faites aux élus elles sont en haute vous
avez demandé à Roanne aux Français ce
qu'il pense de ce phénomène est six
estiment que les réponses de l'État sont
suffisantes on va voir les réponses et
comme tous les mois vous avez scruté la
côte de popularité de l'exécutif la
réforme des retraites
peste d'Emmanuel Macron et d'Elizabeth
borne on va voir tout ça mais d'abord
place à la dictée celle des élus qui se
déroulaient ce week-end au Sénat pour la
troisième fois ils étaient 300 à tenter
le sang faute notre journaliste Adrien
pain à ce côté les copies cet après-midi
là ils ne sont pas au Sénat pour rédiger
des amendements mais pour plancher sur
une dictée qu'il soit sénateur député ou
mère les élus redeviennent des élèves sa
salle Médicis se transforme en salle de
classe et l'organisateur rachid Santaki
et la ministre Agnès firmant le Baudot
joue les professeurs à tour de rôle
[Musique]
en 300 participants une moitié sur place
l'autre moitié en distanciel armée de
leur stylo concentration maximale face
aux difficultés du texte et pour cause
ils n'ont pas été ménagé un mot de 36
lettres qui n'existe pas c'est par
exemple glissé dans le texte
[Musique]
c'est qui
pédalo phobie comme il n'y a pas
vraiment de surveillance certains cèdent
discrètement de leur téléphone où jette
vite un œil sur la copie du voisin
première correction se fait
collectivement chacun compte ses propres
fautes j'en ai eu 13 aussi un petit peu
honte de le dire
que j'ai commencé
l'année prochaine sûrement dans les 8
fautes il y en a 6 qui sont en fait les
expressions que j'ai mis au pluriel
alors qu'elle devrait être au singulier
ou l'inverse moi j'estime je n'en ai que
deux mais bon voilà c'est ça reste avec
ça reste un exercice qu'on fait j'irai
mec un état d'esprit qui n'est pas
d'état d'esprit de compétition des
années après avoir quitté les bancs de
l'école c'est une occasion de tester son
orthographe pour certains je suis 10
donc dyslexique et dysorthographique et
donc faire que 17 fautes considère c'est
un très bon résultat pour moi quand t'as
Philippe Rio est le meilleur maire du
monde en 2021 une figure pas cette
fois-ci en tête du classement
orthographe n'a pas évolué avec les
années mais je pensais faire pire donc
je suis content et c'était c'était
vraiment un bon moment très chouette les
meilleurs copies sont repassés au peigne
fin place au résultat la grande gagnante
remporte l'organisation d'une dictée du
même type dans sa commune
depuis 10 ans Rachid Santaki cumule plus
de 500 dictées à son actif la maîtrise
des mots c'est une alternative à la
violence c'est l'accès à la culture
c'est l'insertion professionnelle c'est
la communication c'est la cohésion
sociale donc c'est aussi un moyen une
manière ludique de rappeler bah en fait
tous ces éléments et l'importance des
mots parmi ces prochaines dictées
prévues une se déroulera dimanche
prochain sur les Champs-Élysées et voilà
pour cette dictée Alex vous auriez fait
un sans faute
le baromètre au dos que ça va remettre
mensuel pour Public Sénat et la presse
régionale le thème ce mois-ci à Roanne
c'était les violences les violences
envers les élus à l'ex d'abord les
chiffres de ce baromètre avec vous et
oui c'est intéressant car le regard des
Français sur la sécurité de nos élus
varie en fonction du type d'élus
concernant les parlementaires 70% des
personnes interrogées estiment qu'ils
sont en sécurité en revanche pour nos
élus locaux seulement 36% pense que leur
sécurité est bien assurée quand on
s'intéresse à la sécurité des lieux qui
sont occupés par nos élus à 57% des
Français pensent que les résidences
personnelles des élus sont bien
sécurisées et concernant les permanences
d'élus même opinion 56% estiment que la
sécurité de ces permanences est assurée
alors faut-il renforcer les sanctions
pénales pour les auteurs de violence
contre les élus la réponse est clair et
net oui à 80%. et on va revenir en
détail sur ces chiffres Erwan mais
d'abord plus largement
la démission du maire de Saint-Brévin on
a créé un peu un électrochoc un
peut-être dans l'opinion qu'elle regarde
porte les Français sur ses violences
envers les élus mais justement c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est quand on
regarde les résultats du sondage de voir
qu'on a finalement deux tiers des
Français avec une lisent la sécurité des
élus locaux et mal assurés alors que la
sécurité des députés et des sénateurs ou
des permanences et bien assuré il y a
quand même un deux poids de mesure dans
l'opinion entre ce qui pense concernant
les députés et sénateurs dans lesquels
ils ont une moins grande confiance et
les élus locaux qui sont les élus
auxquelles ils sont les plus attachés ça
montre bien toute l'incidence et le
retentissement qui a eu dans l'opinion
les dans l'opinion les événements de
Saint-Brevin alors même qu'il y a de
nombreuses permanences de députés qui
ont été vandalisés ces dernières années
même pendant la réforme des retraites
des députés de la majorité
présidentielle notamment donc il y a
quand même une différence et ce qu'on
voit dans sondage c'est que les les élus
locaux apparaissent comme un peu les
parents pauvres de la sécurité alors
c'est l'adage en politique de dire
qu'ils sont apportés d'engueulade c'est
une réalité qui est connue des Français
et ils expriment aussi peut-être leur
inquiétude à la suite de ces événements
dans le sondage sur je souhaite que les
mesures soient durci quand on s'en prend
à des élus évidemment les Français
quelle que soit leur sympathie politique
c'est important de le souligner sont
favorables à un durcissement des
sanctions pénales parce qu'il y a une
sacralité de l'élu dans l'opinion et qui
n'est pas démenti par ce sondage
effectivement la différence est énorme
clair entre les élus nationaux et les
élus locaux dans la perception qu'on les
Français de leur sécurité oui je pense
qu'il y a un effet actu je pense qu'on
en a beaucoup parlé après la démission
du maire de Saint-Brévin et c'est vrai
que c'est assez surprenant parce que
quand on se replonge un peu comme je
l'ai fait dans cette émission sur la
séquence évidemment des gilets jaunes
déjà la réforme des retraites avant le
covid ensuite le passe vaccinal il y a
eu des voilà des voitures incendiées des
menaces de mort à tel point que le pôle
national de lutte contre la haine en
ligne a mené à agréger toutes ces
plaintes voilà pour pour faire une
enquête parce que c'est vrai que
certains élus locaux c'est beaucoup plus
difficile voilà de retrouver les auteurs
quand on est sur des micros enquêtes on
a eu des les présidents de groupes à
l'ASSE nationale qui est en 2021 on fait
une tribune pour dire il faut que ça
cesse voilà donc il y a vraiment c'est
vrai un mouvement qu'on a presque oublié
qui avait comme été oubliée par cet
événement tragique donc je pense que
c'est vrai qu'il faut voilà il y a un
effet actu peut-être le contrôle dans ce
dans ce sondage et que et qui je pense
effectivement et peut-être avoir avec le
la sympathie à apporter aux élus locaux
qui sont moins politisés sur des
problématiques plus de la vie
quotidienne dans un moment où le débat
public est très clivé très blanc donc
c'est ça explique peut-être cet écart
qui effectivement est troublant et assez
loin en fait de la réalité que vivent
les députés alors majorité ou pas parce
que il y a quand même des élus de tout
bord qui sont au niveau national victime
de violence dans leur dans leur
circonscription dans l'ordre dans leur
permanence à leur domicile voilà donc
c'est ouais ça s'explique par un effet
actu comme comme le dit clair l'écart
assez conséquent oui national qui est
qui est palpable on l'a vu sur les
réseaux sociaux il y a énormément de
commentaires autour de la démission à
Saint-Brevin des incidents des récents
mères qui ont démissionné par solidarité
c'est quelque chose qui a extrêmement
marqué l'opinion alors que peut-être la
question de la permanences vandalisée
c'était avait été condamné mais c'était
restreint dans le cadre politique là on
voit qu'il y a le l'opinion publique
c'est emparé de ce sujet mais une
proximité des élus aujourd'hui si
Français sur 10 s'exprime qu'ils ont
confiance dans leur mère on est
quasiment à moitié moins en ce qui
concerne leur députés donc il y a
peut-être ce poids aussi de la proximité
qui joue dans les mois national et dans
l'ampleur du retentissement que ça a eu
dans l'opinion et d'autant que la
démission du maire de Saint-Brévin elle
a libéré la parole on a vu beaucoup dans
la presse régionale dans vos journaux
claire des témoignages de mer tout à
fait nous on a beaucoup traité ça au
niveau local d'autant plus qu'on est ami
mandat donc c'était aussi l'occasion un
peu de faire le point et c'est vrai
qu'on a eu des maires dans les airs dans
le Rhône qui expliquait un des cas de
figure extrêmement divers ça peut être
aussi pour des histoires de trafic de
drogue comme à Bron par exemple ou un
mère a été victime de caler à ça j'ai
reçu des menaces il peut y avoir des
choses beaucoup plus voilà on entre
guillemets
habituel j'ai par rapport à des élus
qu'on voulait peut-être proche de la
majorité à qui on a reproché voilà une
proximité avec les Macron avec Emmanuel
Macron pardon parce ce genre de choses
mais c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
qui voilà qui qui est très présent
aujourd'hui une préoccupation et on voit
que il y a quand même des choses qui
sont faites déjà un cercle là on voit il
y a eu des à la suite de cette de cette
démission qui a qui a fait grand bruit
et des mesures ont été annoncées mais
les éludis que bah ils étaient pas tout
seul mais c'est pour seul à gérer ces
situations déjà il y avait des réunions
avec les préfets pour voilà libérer la
parole recueillir des plaintes il y a
des choses qui étaient déjà faites mais
là c'est vrai qu'on voit que ça ça a
suscité de la part du gouvernement une
prise de conscience comme vous disiez
peut-être un électrochoc dans la
nécessité de de en tout cas de
généraliser ces bonnes pratiques et de
faire en sorte que vraiment les élus se
sentent plus seules dans ces situations
et que l'évaluation du risque soit bien
faite et dans l'opinion aussi
Erwan ça a été un tournant à la
démission du maire de Saint-Brévin il y
a une forme de prise de conscience aussi
chez les Français pas forcément un
tournant mais je pense que c'est
vraiment à la mesure de ce qu'on peut
observer dans les sondages dès lors
qu'on sensibilise sur des questions de
sécurité des personnes qui sont au
service des citoyens on a pu la voir
pour les forces de l'ordre qu'on a des
débordements par exemple dans les
manifestations dans les cortèges on a
toujours cette question du durcissement
des sanctions pour les auteurs de
violence à l'égard des forces de l'ordre
on l'a aussi pour les pompiers pour les
médecins et les élus locaux et les élus
de façon plus générale ça rentre dans
cette case pour pour les Français
aujourd'hui la condamnation est unanime
c'est vrai qu'il y a un effet loop avec
l'actualité mais je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'assez transverse et qui
n'a pas évolué ces dernières années sur
la sacralité de l'élu et le fait de
pouvoir assurer sa sécurité aucune
différence dans les Français que vous
interrogez selon les sympathies
politiques il y a aucune différence sur
ces questions là il y a un delta qui est
léger c'est à dire que le le souhaite
durcissement des sanctions est
légèrement inférieur chez les
sympathisants la France insoumise mais
il est de 60% là où on est à 80% la
moyenne des Français c'est majoritaire
quel que soit la sympathie politique des
Français il n'y a pas de sujet à débat
dans l'opinion et ça répond aussi clair
à une demande peut-être chez les
Français de plus d'autorité de la part
de l'État
c'est un débat c'est vrai qu'on va voir
on voit il y a des à chaque type de
comment dire d'événements d'émotions sa
proposition de l'axe soit sur les
casseurs que ce soit là sur la sécurité
des élus encore une fois beaucoup de
choses elles avaient été avaient été
déjà faites je voulais juste préciser
quand même que là on était dans la
Saint-Brévin dans un cas de figure qui
n'était pas lors de la défiance par
rapport à un élu on était dans une
menace par des groupuscules d'extrême
droite qui venaient même pas vraiment de
cette zone là avec une organisation très
structurée donc je pense notamment sur
le delta par rapport à l'extrême gauche
enfin à la France insoumise c'est lié à
cette analyse de la situation qu'on a vu
lors de la manifestation de soutien aux
maires qui a été dit de politisée ou
récupérer mais c'est vrai qu'on a dans
l'opinion la perception que là c'était
aussi se mobiliser contre l'extrême
droite contre la là on avait quand même
un centre d'accueil de demandeur d'asile
qui a suscité de les mois c'est assez
différent de ce qui peut se passer sur
sur d'autres mers ou qui sont comme vous
disiez à portée de baffe parce que
quelque chose ne fonctionne pas parce
que là voilà ou qu'il y a une des choses
par rapport à la représentation la
volonté de pouvoir s'exprimer
directement donc je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses qui qui viennent
là-dedans après oui que je pense que
l'audition au Sénat du maire de
Saint-Brévin a vraiment montré des
dysfonctionnements dans la perception de
la menace dans la la réalité de de voilà
de la prise en considération de ce qu'il
vivait de la façon qu'il était exposé
donc aujourd'hui on remette les choses à
plat je pense qu'il y a consensus aussi
parce qu'on se dit il faut que c'est ces
personnes qui sont en première ligne
qu'ils ont une responsabilité énorme qui
sont assez presque un sacerdos quand on
les entend enfin alors ils sont
réveillés la nuit ils travaillent enfin
il y a plus d'eau il y a un incendie ils
sont ils sont sur le enfin ils sont là
tout le temps pour pour leurs
administrer que ils aient un statut oui
particulier ça paraît ça paraît logique
mais je pense que c'est c'est moins une
demande sécuritaire qu'une demande de
respect et de et de protection de leur
voilà de leur rôle qui aujourd'hui est
primordial et on le voit bien là est-ce
qu'il va y avoir des mecs qui vont se
présenter qui vont se représenter aux
élections c'est un vrai sujet les
vocations à être mère je pense que il y
a un enjeu là alors ils étaient 7 sur 10
à être pessimiste pour l'année 2023 les
maires quand on les interrogeait en
décembre 2022 parce que c'est vrai
qu'ils ont voyagé la crise énergétique
il y a la question des ressources des
communes il y a les éléments de sécurité
mais là ce qui est important c'est
vraiment de souligner ce souhait
d'autorité des Français dès lors qu'il y
a des débordements et des violences et
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve dans
les sondages en filigranes et en montée
progressive depuis quelques années le
souhait d'hostilité et de fermeté face à
la violence non pas sur ce sur la
question aussi bien des forces de
l'ordre comme on l'a dans les
manifestations mais ça peut être le cas
pour les médecins quand il y a des faits
divers c'est vrai que le fait divers
crée un effet loop mais il y a vraiment
cette demande d'autorité qui est assez
forte et qu'on constate effectivement au
delà des élus un roi de leur rappeler il
y a aussi à la question des personnels
soignants la question des forces de
l'ordre c'est une demande d'autorité qui
se généralise qui s'accentue on est dans
une période troublée
de mobilisation des Mobilis
[Musique]
par rapport au mois dernier mais une
cote qui reste quand même assez basse à
31% des Français qui estiment
qu'Emmanuel Macron est un bon Président
de la République du côté d'Elizabeth
borne et bien sa popularité ne varie pas
par rapport au mois dernier là aussi
elle est assez faible 28% des Français
pensent que c'est une bonne première
ministre une relative stabilité alors
les chiffres sont toujours bas
Erwan mais son stables comment
l'explique alors ce qui ce qu'il faut
noter c'est que à 31% de bonnes opinions
Emmanuel Macron est juste 4 points au
dessus son score le plus bas à l'Élysée
depuis 2017 c'était au moment des gilets
jaunes étaient tombés à 27%. est
toujours cette Français sur 10 qui
considère qu'il n'est pas un bon
président et la séquence des retraites
n'est clairement pas dépassée on était à
41% de bonnes opinions en décembre 2022
avant qu'il relance la réforme des
retraites on est 10 points en dessous
aujourd'hui mais il y a un signe quand
même frémissement positif pour le chef
de l'État c'est qu'on observe dans ce
qu'on pourrait appeler des électorats
périphériques ou Macron compatibles une
petite progression
bonnes opinions on a une augmentation de
plus de 10 points auprès des
sympathisants LR 54% de bonnes opinions
chez sympathisants a l'air plus de 10
points également chez les sympathisants
socialistes on a aussi des gains de
popularité chez les cadres et les
indépendants alors on est ni sur la
réconciliation nationale ni sur le
dépassement de la séquence des retraites
mais peut-être sur un plancher positif
pour le chef de l'état où il regagne un
peu de crédit auprès d'un électorat
élargi et le quinquennat pourrait
redémarrer dans une version réformatrice
alors que peut-être avec la fin des
casseroles aussi il donne le sentiment
d'être moins empêché et d'être revenu au
premier plan de façon efficace pour
Elisabeth borne c'est peut-être un peu
plus compliqué de décoller ce sparadrap
de la réforme des retraites parce que
elle dans une certaine mesure une grande
partie de son image a été construite
dans la séquence de la réforme des
retraites qui était négative donc ça
peut être plus difficile pour la chef du
gouvernement de dépasser cette séquence
en ce qui concerne Emmanuel Macron on
est vraiment sur une étape préalable
mais on reste quand même très sur une
popularité très tirée à la baisse par la
séquence retraite un début d'après
réforme des retraites qui se dessine
clair c'est difficile je pense que oui
il exécutif on voit bien on fait tout ce
qu'il peut pour tourner la page donc on
a eu la séquence ce tourbillon c'est
stratégie du tourbillon présidentiel où
il était dans des déplacements locaux
dans la presse régionale dans la presse
nationale on a eu donc jusqu'à cette
interview sur TF1 le 15 le 15 mai
vraiment avec des annonces tous azimuts
vers les Kalas moyennes sur ses
priorités donc l'écologie l'éducation la
santé enfin on a vu que vraiment une
volonté de voilà de de tourner la page
mais qui quelque part fait en fait
office de faux plat enfin ce que disent
un peu les les élus ces sentiments de
creux là dans l'actualité peut-être
aussi au pont mais qui font que on garde
quand même en ligne de mire cette
proposition de Loi sur l'abrogation de
la réforme des retraites le 8 juin que
l'opposition aussi accroche même si pour
certains voilà les factuellement ça a
très très peu de chance d'aboutir avec
cette journée du 6 juin de mobilisation
ça reste quand même l'horizon on en est
pas sorti de cette séquence enfin moi
j'ai le sentiment que de chaque côté il
y a cette volonté soit de de d'y ramener
et d'obtenir voilà de ne pas accepter
cette défaite politique pour
l'opposition et le gouvernement de se
dire voilà ça y est on est passé à autre
chose mais j'ai pas l'impression moi que
dans les fêtes on en soit vraiment on en
soit vraiment sorti ouais c'est pas
encore tourné est-ce que la proposition
de loi du groupe du 8 juin ça ça imprime
dans l'opinion airwan est-ce que les
opposants à la réforme des retraites il
s'y accrochent ou pour eux c'est peine
perdue alors ici accroche pas forcément
dans la mesure où la résignation a quand
même beaucoup pris le pas sur la colère
si on compare les résultats ce qu'on
pourrait mesurer il y a deux mois mais
ils sont tous majoritairement favorables
évidemment au mouvement social du du 8
juin et à la loi d'abrographie
maintenant le sujet c'est quand même
qu'il y a une confiance dans le
processus législatif qui s'est beaucoup
émoussé entre le 47 ans le 49.3 le
rotokage du référendum d'initiative
populaire donc toutes ces questions là
ont quand même beaucoup émoussé la
confiance dans le processus législatif
je pense que les Français sont
favorables à l'abrogation de la réforme
des retraites mais attendre quand même
de voir comment ça peut se dérouler
concrètement il y a une forme d'attente
de la part des Français avec la
en tout cas il y a un petit trou d'air
j'ai moi j'ai l'impression que j'ai
c'est qu'effectivement il y a cette
volonté même si on est dans le symbole
et on voit bien quand même que les
efforts que que la majorité met en
oeuvre pour que cet article 1 qui
abroche donc le report de l'âge légal
tout en disant qu'il n'a aucune chance
d'aboutir ce qui est fait actuellement
vrai puisque le Sénat n'a aucune chance
de la accepter enfin de le voter qui
ensuite on aurait une navette
interminable enfin mais c'est un symbole
et en fait le fait que cette cet article
qui n'a jamais été voté donc c'est c'est
important c'est le discours de
l'opposition soit voter à ce moment là
fait naître au moins un espoir je sais
pas si ce que vous dit voilà de de
réparer un processus démocratique qui
pour beaucoup elle n'a pas été respectée
même si légalement il était de dire
qu'il faut que ça ça passe au vote donc
on voit bien qu'en même temps on entend
dire que ça n'a aucune chance d'aboutir
quand même temps c'est un symbole et à
des efforts des multiplier pour que
quand même on aille au vote qu'on aille
au débat sur cet article donc je pense
que ça a une portée symbolique mais qui
montre bien et on l'a vu dans la
chronologie de la mobilisation ce
recours aux 49-3 a montré une a marqué
une rupture ça peut même dans le camp
présidentiel on a vu dans les sondages
que certaines personnes dit là non même
si cette vraie forme on l'accepte on a
on a même voté pour un président qui l'a
porté ce recours au 49-3 était vu comme
un passage enfant et donc je dis pas que
ça a une vertu réparatrice mais c'est
vrai que il y a quelque chose qui se
cristallise autour de ce voilà de cette
de cette d'abord recevabilité on en
parlait tout à l'heure il y a l'article
40 qui a surgi dans le débat qui est
voilà donc on savait qu'on connaît tous
les détails la loi constitutionnelle
maintenant sur est-ce que c'est
recevable ou pas mais c'est vrai qu'on
se dit non pas encore une fois pas
encore une fois on va pas nous priver de
se débat là et je trouve que dans le
discours actuel sur la représentativité
sur la représentation sur plus de
référendum de c'est important ça doit
pas être balayé même si on voit bien
qu'on arrive au bout et que quelque part
les gens qui vont partir à la retraite
prochainement ont besoin de savoir quand
est-ce qu'ils vont partir à la retraite
la ça commence à voilà c'est c'est quand
même ça ça approche pour le gouvernement
c'est de minimiser le coût politique le
coup en termes de popularité de cette
séquence de la proposition de loi
d'abrogation de la réforme des retraites
alors il y a une solution c'est d'aller
au vote mais c'est un risque pour le
gouvernement et si jamais ce texte cette
réforme de retraite et abrogée et que
Emmanuel Macron décide quand même de
l'appliquer là il y aura un coup très
fort en terme de popularité l'autre
solution c'est de déclencher l'article
40 et de déclarer et recevable cette
réforme des retraites quitte et bien à
interrompre voire annuler le débat là
aussi ça peut être problématique pour le
gouvernement et tous les reproches
finalement des opposants qui en
anti-démocratie qui sont faits au
gouvernement ça ça pourra revenir il y a
une autre solution qui est peut-être
aussi être travaillée c'est de faire un
petit peu d'obstruction dans les débats
car on sera sur un débat en temps limité
jusqu'à minuit et peut-être que les
députés de la majorité présidentielle
vont faire durer les débats comme l’ont
fait les insoumis dans le débat de la
réforme des retraites donc voilà il y a
un calcul du coût de popularité et
Erwan
le rappeler le 49-3 c'est à cristallisé
quelque chose dans l'opinion est-ce que
là si le débat est empêché le 8 juin ça
va re cristalliser à nouveau quelque
chose oui bien entendu parce que ça les
Français ont dans une certaine mesure un
espèce de d'apriori un préjugé négatif
sur le tenant démocratique de ce qui est
mis en place par la majorité et là
finalement ça fournirait un élément de
preuve de passage en force démocratique
et d'irrespects démocratique et c'est
vrai que c'est on avait vu ce double
mouvement pendant la réforme des
retraites une contestation idéologique
du passage de 62 à 64 ans mais aussi une
contestation démocratique sur la forme
qui a pesé énormément et même qui a
écarté d'Emmanuel Macron des personnes
qui soutenaient l'idéologie et le le la
loi le programme la programmatique
macronienne qui finalement sur le la
méthode sont venues assez critiques et
du coup cette question là elle va être
très importante parce que ça va ça va
permettre de juger aussi au-delà du
programme Macron la méthode Macron et
c'est vrai que s'il pouvait y avoir une
Recon une réconciliation sur ce point là
ce serait gagné en termes de popularité
pour les chefs de l'État on avait vu que
les sessions houleuses à l'Assemblée
nationale elle est fortement de crédité
les députés dans dans l'opinion ils
perdent beaucoup de points de popularité
dans le baromètre de la confiance
politique cette année donc il y a quand
même aussi une question de restaurer du
crédit sur la méthode et la mise en
place de de projets et de loi et il y a
un vrai enjeu de ce côté là aussi ça
veut dire que le gouvernement clair il a
le choix entre deux mauvaises solutions
finalement empêcher le débat ce qui est
créerait un ressentiment dans l'opinion
ou aller au vote avec le risque de le
perdre ce qui renforcerait et ce qui
relancerait la contestation
après enfin je suis pas je suis pas
experte mais de ce que j'ai compris même
si l'Assemblée nationale votait cette
proposition pourrait capacité à voter
dans les mêmes termes donc en fait en
vrai ce serait une défaite symbolique
c'est-à-dire que l'Assemblée nationale
notamment avec le rôle pivot que va
jouer là puisqu'on a quand même dans une
ça a été la grande bataille pour pour le
premier examen et là on sait que dès
demain en commission en commission ça va
être un vrai sujet que vont faire les
députés là moi si jamais c'était votre
c'est un symbole mais ça n'irait pas
plus loin effectivement ça montrerait
qu'il y avait une majorité pour refuser
ce lois donc même si
constitutionnellement de ce que je
voyage je comprends de cette procédure
il y a peu de chances que ce soit
vraiment adopté c'est effectivement ce
serait la preuve que cette loi n'avait
pas une majorité derrière elle à
l'Assemblée qu'elle n'aurait pas pu
qu'elle n'aurait pas pu passer donc je
pense qu'effectivement pour le
gouvernement le gouvernement beaucoup à
perdre mais comme disait Erwan de ne pas
aller au vote peu de nouveau attiser la
violence dans les rues enfin ce qu'on a
vu parce que c'est vrai que tout le
mouvement jusqu'à jusqu'au recours au
49-3 était maîtrisé par les syndicats on
en avait parlé ici c'est vrai qu'ils
avaient quand même une maîtrise dans la
gestion de ce mouvement social qui a
dérapé on l'a vu dans beaucoup de villes
avec ces incendies
voilà on ne sait pas enfin la volonté
d'apaisement effectivement là il y a un
vrai dilemme pour le gouvernement
qui est le gagnant de cette séquence
dans le baromètre politique alors comme
tous les mois on a envie de dire c'est
Édouard Philippe qui est en tête mais il
y a une remontée Marine Le Pen Erwan oui
un niveau historique c'est à dire
qu'elle n'avait jamais atteint une côte
d'adhésion aussi où tu en as 36% de
personnes qu'il a soutiennent ou qui ont
de la sympathie pour elle et voir Marine
Le Pen à ce niveau là au-delà du chiffre
c'est intéressant parce que dans les
baromètres politiques souvent les
personnalités qu'on a aux premières
places c'est des personnalités assez
consensuelles de centre droit ou de
centre gauche ça peut être Alain Juppé
pendant très longtemps Nicolas Hulot
aujourd'hui Édouard Philippe a revoir
une personnalité marquée à l'extrême
droite en tête de ce classement c'est
éducatif et ça indique peut-être
en troisième position mais ça indique
vraiment qu'on est peut-être même
au-delà de la stratégie de normalisation
du rassemblement national qui est
dépassé et que finalement il y a une
stratégie d'enjolivement même qui a été
dépassé c'est que non seulement c'est
plus une figure nue au nid Marine Le Pen
mais c'est même une figure appréciée qui
a gagné des points d'image et on parlait
de cette écart avec les attentes
démocratiques et idéologiques des
français quand on quand on comparait
avant le deuxième tour l'image de Marine
Le Pen et d'Emmanuel Macron mais
Emmanuel Macron avait l'air très peu
proche des gens quand Marine Le Pen
avait l'image d'une candidate qui
comprenait les préoccupations des
Français et le et la différence est
peut-être là-dedans c'est que cette
proximité idéologique avec le quotidien
des Français à raison ou à tort dans
l'opinion ça permet à Marine Le Pen de
marquer des points
la gagnante de cette séquence pour le
moment
il semblerait c'est à dire que ils ont
mené un combat à l'Assemblée à minima en
marquant chaque étape législative en
montrant leur opposition mais en
s'opposant à une vraiment une
mobilisation dans la rue ils ont été un
symbole de modération de respect des
institutions ce qui est voilà la carte
vraiment qui a joué depuis son entrée à
l'Assemblée avec un important groupe et
qui semblerait qu'effectivement ça
fonctionne au-delà des classes
traditionnelles enfin des catégories qui
votaient pour elle merci merci Erwan
merci Claire vous restez avec nous c'est
l'heure de la revue de presse régionale
mais avant de regarder ce qu'elle a une
de vos quotidiens régionaux on va aller
à Marseille puisque le journal La
Provence se refait une beauté bonjour et
bienvenue merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous directeur des rédactions de la
Provence et nouvelle formule ce matin
dans les kiosques Aurélien d'abord sur
la forme qu'est-ce qui va changer pour
vos lecteurs
alors beaucoup de choses on avait un
maquette de journal qui n'avait pas
changé depuis 2008 donc depuis très
longtemps et là on a une nouvelle
maquette entièrement redesignée beaucoup
plus aéré beaucoup plus dynamique avec
plus de blanc comme on dit dans la
presse beaucoup plus d'espace et vous
voyez cette une et bien elle est bien à
l'image de ce qu'on veut faire pour la
Provence c'est-à-dire qu'on est plus
prospectif on va annoncer davantage
d'événements comme là les dix dates de
l'été on fait des choix ont eu avant il
y avait beaucoup plus d'informations en
une on avait jusqu'à 15 infos visibles
sur la manchette sur la sur la sur la
couverture de la Provence et maintenant
vous voyez que vous avez des choix
beaucoup plus tranchés comme cette
grande photo ce grand titre avec Beyoncé
qu'on va accueillir au Vélodrome bientôt
à Marseille et puis dans la région on a
aussi le Festival d'Avignon les
rencontres photos d'Arles le festival
d'art lyrique à Aix-en-Provence le delta
festival donc on a plein d'artisans dans
la région et c'est cette richesse
culturel le qu'on veut aussi davantage
mettre en avant
sur le fond vous le disiez avec votre
une qui change ça on l'a vu qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de nouveau on a vu aussi les
pages intérieures de la Provence qui
avec de nouvelles maquettes un nouveau
design
oui c'était entièrement repensé donc
c'est beaucoup plus dynamique aéré on a
beaucoup plus on travaille sur des
différentes colonnes et différentes
mises en scène de l'information et on
voulait une information davantage
hiérarchisée également qu'on s'y
retrouve plus et qu'on est aussi des
entrées pour mieux se repérer des
nouvelles entrées des nouveaux
rendez-vous on a notamment une page
idéale qui prend forme aujourd'hui et on
a repensé vraiment toutes les pages du
journal les pages sport les pages villes
les pages région donc c'est vraiment une
nouvelle maquette très au goût du jour
et on revoit la une la une avec Beyoncé
vous le traitez en
didida de la Provence que vous êtes
venus nous présenter ce matin merci
beaucoup Aurélien on était ravi de vous
avoir dans cette émission et merci
beaucoup d'être venu nous présenter
notre votre nouvelle maquette de la
Provence à retrouver bien sûr ce matin
dans vos kiosques merci Aurélien regarde
si elle est une de vos autres quotidiens
les choses aussi avec Alex
[Musique]
on commence par le sommet mondial sur la
pollution plastique c'est à la ligne de
Sud-Ouest 175 pays sont réunis cette
semaine à Paris pour ébaucher un traité
international censé mettre fin à la
pollution plastique chaque année dans le
monde nous produisons 460 millions de
tonnes de plastique 80% finit en
montagne de déchets une pollution qui
frappe nos océans chaque minute 15
tonnes de plastique sont rejetés dans
les mers et les océans lors de ce sommet
international de quand vont s'affronter
lors des négociations les pays qui
privilégie le recyclage car il ne veut
ils ne veulent pas mettre à mal leur
industrie pétrochimique c'est le cas des
États-Unis des pays du Golfe et de la
Chine et puis il y a les pays qui
prônent plus d'ambition avec une baisse
de la production de plastique ce camp
est emmené par l'Union européenne de la
Dépêche du Midi c'est la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre oui la grande pénurie titre le
journal toulousain 87% des entreprises
en France qui cherchent à embaucher ont
du mal à trouver le bon profil ce qui
crée un manque de confiance dans
l'économie 63% des chefs d'entreprise
français redoutent un manque de main
d'oeuvre dans cette année à venir et
parmi les métiers où les plus difficiles
de recruter il y a les couvreurs les
pharmaciens et les aides à domicile dans
le secteur de l'hôtellerie restauration
c'est aussi compliqué il y a 200 000
emplois pour voir d'ici à l'été les
entrepreneurs doivent s'adapter
notamment aux jeunes qui réclament des
conditions de travail plus confortables
pas d'heure supplémentaires et pas de
travail le week-end en revanche sur le
marché du logement et bien les jeunes
sont beaucoup moins en position de force
dans quelques jours on connaîtra les
premiers résultats de la plateforme
parcoursup la plateforme d'admission
dans l'enseignement supérieur et va
alors commencer une course au logement
pour les étudiants c'est à la Une de
Nord éclair dans la métropole lilloise
elle est 110 000 étudiants devront se
loger entre le parc privé et les 6000
chambres universitaires que compte la
métropole à l'île même et ben il y a peu
de résidences universitaires à cause du
prix du foncier et de l'immobilier les
étudiants vont donc plus se rabattre sur
le marché privé et puis globalement sur
le territoire français et bien la
recherche de logements pour les
étudiants s'annonce très difficile car
le marché
est tendu avec des loyers en forte
hausse dans certaines villes à Lyon par
exemple il y a en moyenne cinq demandes
d'étudiants pour un studio à louer on
termine par l'un des journaux du groupe
les bras c'est bien vous allez nous
parler d'un procès hors norme à Dijon
l'affaire du Capricorne vous savez ce
que c'est le Capricorne et bien c'est un
insecte ravageur d'échappantes et il est
l'objet d'une arnaque géante ce mardi
débute un procès autour justement de
cette arnaque la cour d'appel de Dijon
va juger neuf hommes pour escroquerie en
bande organisée au préjudice de 400
personnes âgées propriétaires et vivant
toutes dans le Grand Est entre 2010 et
2016 et bien les accusés auraient
prétexter la présence de ces capricornes
un secteur ravageur dans les charpentes
des maisons des victimes pour les
pousser à faire des travaux
inutiles et aller surfacturer certaines
personnes âgées ont du contracter des
crédits à la consommation et se sont
mises en difficulté financières montant
de cette arnaque plus de 6 millions
d'euros voilà maintenant on sait ce
qu'elle a à faire du Capricorne merci
beaucoup Alex on va regarder deux autres
journaux du groupe Evra il y en a
beaucoup claire on en
a les Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace sur
les JO Jo l'épreuve de la sécurité ça
fait partie des thèmes abordés ce matin
dans vos journaux merci beaucoup
d'être venu nous présenter comme tous
les mois ce baromètre doxa pour mener le
mois prochain
merci beaucoup Alex nous on se retrouve
demain pour voir revoir cette émission
c'est sur notre nouvelle plateforme
public sénat.fr prochain rendez-vous à
18h Thomas Hut France public très bonne
journée à demain
[Musique]